I'm Josh Hutcherson and this is the
wired autocomplete
[Music]
interview did I do something
probably what is Josh Hutcherson known
for I'm known for making movies and now
I'm a meme I'm happy about that but I'm
excited to get back to being known for
movies as well how did Josh Hutcherson
become an actor I was a young boy uh The
Ripe young age of age of 9 years old I
got out of foone book which many of you
might not be familiar with I called an
agency in Cincinnati and said that I
want to be an actor and they were like
let's talk to your parents and I was
like well they're at work then my
parents were like this kid will not stop
and they got behind me and then we drove
to California stayed in the motel and uh
started making movies Josh Hutcherson
new movie yeah I have The Beekeeper
which is coming out now January 12th
this guy Derek that I play in beekeeper
is like completely unhinged he's a
crypto bro multi-billionaire privileged
if I may say so just kind of
getting to play something that out there
in Wild was uh it's a lot of fun where
has Josh Hutcherson been I've been
taking it easy recharged my batteries
fallen in love again with being on set
and working hard and you're not going to
have to ask this one what Josh
Hutcherson character are you I'm not
Derek Danforth from The Beekeeper I'm
not Peta because I don't have blonde
hair anymore I might be closest to like
Mike from Five Nights at Freddy's in a
way he's like from a smaller town salt
of the earth kind of guy I connect with
that
kid Josh Hutcherson Hometown I am from
Union Kentucky it's a lovely place when
I drink bourbon that's when the Kentucky
really comes out the accent starts to
slip and then all of a sudden it's like
rber Derber and then it just all goes
downhill Josh Hutson mullet I would love
to rock a mullet my guy who cuts my hair
he's always like do you want to do the
mullet thing and I'm always like yeah
but I'm scared is this a sign I mean
this is a sign but like maybe I should
go for it Josh Hutson siblings yes I
have my little brother Connor he's the
best we're super close our parents
always made it very important that like
the family had to be together like
maximum like two weeks apart 3 weeks
apart kind of thing and whatever film
that I was making we would have it in my
contract as like an 11-year-old that
they would get extra plane tickets for
my dad and brother to be able to come
out and see us we've maintained a very
very good relationship over the years is
Josh Hutcherson a Libra got a tattooed
in case I forget I was 16 when I got
this tattoo I'm actually a double Libra
Libra main one and Libra Rising so I'm
very uh in search of the balance so they
say I'm happy with it is Josh Hutson
fluent and
Spanish
so
basically why Josh Hutcherson became a
meme I know my girlfriend like I guess
she posted something on Instagram and
then the comments just became people
like with this Meme and this meme looked
into it and she was like baby there's
some meme of you from 2014 whistle video
and I was like I don't know what this is
and then I found out and it's like a
thing why was Josh Hutcherson dancing
cuz I was dancing why aren't you dancing
why was anybody ever dancing because
dancing is great Josh Hutson Ultram man
I dubbed this really cool show uh for
Netflix called Ultram man it's like a a
Japanese anime type show and they came
to me to do a season of this like a few
years ago but it's a really cool show
and and then they actually had me come
back and do another season of it and
hopefully more they had the original in
Japanese they've done a translation and
you're trying to match basically the
syll
in the translation but it doesn't always
fit so it's like a fun creative
challenge of like how can I rewrite this
line to fit with the syllables and match
what the character is trying to say how
old was Josh Hutcherson in Bridge 2 I'm
going to guess is going to say
Terabithia Terabithia I think I was 12 I
guess I have a little bit of a knack for
finding like beloved books and then
bringing them to life because Bridget
Terabithia was like a required reading
book in many schools and so I think that
it definitely was a great sort of Bridge
to like the rest of my younger career
can Josh
Hutcherson draw I can't I can do like
the like early 2000s s thing CU I used
to write my name that way with j
s h is Josh Hutcherson real yeah I'm
real we're all
real is Josh Hutcherson taken I have a
girlfriend yes but like I'm I'm I'm me
and I'm I'm I'm here for the world is
Josh Hutson fit I can run a fair
distance and I've been on like a new
like Health kick lately but overall I'd
say I'm I'm
fit did Josh
Hutcherson audition for Spider-Man yeah
I did the Andrew Garfield version one of
my friends who had been my stunt double
for a few movies he and I went down to
this like stunt training gym called 8711
and we decided to shoot me doing some
Spider-Man stunts I didn't it but the
crazy thing is like I think a month
after that I got cast in Hunger Games
does Josh
Hutcherson have tattoos one here one
here a huge one on my back that I forget
about because I never see it and then
when I see it in a picture I'm like oh
Jesus that's so big and colorful why I
don't know man I just went through a
phase where I thought I was kind of like
maybe a pirate or something and so I
just would go and get these like Sailor
Jerry massive anchors and boats and
stuff and regrets not the right word
because they remind me of who I was but
it also when I sit down and have to do
like an extra 2 hours of makeup to cover
these tattoos it's like I don't think
it's worth it does Josh Hutcherson sing
no I do not sing one of my biggest this
is a regret is that I never like learned
music or singing or any kind of lessons
like that and they say it's like never
too late to learn something I feel that
like learning instruments and stuff I
can maybe do but singing my voice
doesn't listen to what the note needs to
be does Josh
Hutcherson still play baseball well
there's a thing that us older people do
it's called softball and it's similar
but it's way less risky the ball is
large and soft and I I do play some
softball from time to time with a bunch
of dads like in Echo Park and it's very
uh it's very chill but I did actually
get a softball injury a few months back
and I couldn't run for like 2 weeks and
I was like this is where I'm at who does
Josh Hutcherson
play in Hunger Games Peter malar in the
Hunger Games I always say it was kind of
like my college experience cuz I didn't
go to college it's a weird University it
was a time of my life you know we were
all over the world me Jen Liam Woody
Jenna all had such like a a great tight
group of of like a little family it was
the best man I I miss it I miss it
dearly it was a lot of fun who does Josh
huderson play and FNAF that's Five
Nights at Freddy's for those who don't
know I play Mike Schmidt and I am the
night guard and if you're familiar with
the game you know that that is kind of
the character that you're playing I have
no patience when it comes to video games
so if I'm like especially in the first
iteration of the game if I'm sitting
there I just I need to move and do stuff
and I just kept dying so I'm just going
to live it out in the in the movies and
let you guys keep beating the games does
Josh Hutson know the FNAF lore Piper
Rubio who plays my little sister in five
nights she is hardcore fanatic and last
time I saw her she gave me like a 2hour
breakdown of like the lore of every game
with the characters who come in and they
go and this character is there because
of this and that it was a lot to retain
and I I didn't retain it so I'm not
super familiar with the lore which means
I'm very excited to read the next script
and see where they take it when did Josh
Hutcherson host SNL I've never done
theater or like live performances of any
sort so my first ever like live audience
performance was was hosting Saturday
Night Live it was a lot of fun and just
how hard they work in their process is
absolutely mind-blowing one of the
things that that messed me up the most
is they were like whatever you do do not
try to memorize anything that's like
what I do I memorize and then they're
like no because even after you do the
first live run through they're going to
change the jokes it's got to be on your
feet on your feet and just go for it oh
I would happily do it again well those
are all the boards Google's a weird
place you guys have a lot of interesting
Minds out there yeah it's been
[Music]
fun